hey guys Pete here today I was thinking
about the wall and how it might come
down this is something that most fans
expect to happen in both the show and
the books and since the show is nearing
the end it won't be long until we see it
go boom this video will go over the
history of what we know about the wall
and will contain spoilers if you aren't
caught up to the end of season six in
the show one of the things that came
across when doing research for this
video was the connection to Hadrian's
Wall in Britain George RR Martin's said
that he was influenced by this real
world wall when he came up with the idea
for the wall in the north of Westeros I
won't go too deep into the history of
Hadrian's Wall other than to say it was
a man-made wall that the Romans built to
mark the northern boundary of their
empire it was more or less built to keep
barbarians from moving freely into the
empire from the north the thing I found
interesting about Hadrian's Wall though
was that the reasons for building it
don't make great sense there's no
detailed record of what Hadrian had in
mind it had been left to historians to
decide well there are plenty of
reasonable explanations none of them
make you say oh yeah of course that's
why they built it for a couple of
examples
think about this reason one it was built
for defense this wall was huge on like a
Donald Trump scale and took a lot of
resources to build maintain and defend
how many southern Raiders could it
actually stop and what would that be
worth this investment reason - it was
built as a symbol of the Roman Empire's
power
it was definitely impressive but if the
point was to show off how many people
would actually see this wall without
going down a rabbit hole
why is this important because this isn't
some mysterious time of history that we
don't know much about it's important in
the sense that what history tells us
about the ball might not be very
accurate we'll get back to this idea
later but for now let's look at what
history and legend tell us about our
giant ice wall in the north of Westeros
the wall stretches for 300 miles and is
about 700 feet tall it's made of solid
ice with some stone and earth and you
can see it for miles around
it appears gray or blue depending on
weather and time of day it's fairly wide
at the top you could bride something
like 12 nights across and it's even
water than thicker than that at the base
according to myth there are spells that
are built in as a part of it which helps
to strengthen the structure and it also
keeps out magical creatures such as
the White Walkers from passing through
the wall does not have standard gates
they're just holes but then they're
reinforced with iron bars and massive
chains and you can't get in without
someone you know using a pulley system
to unlock it the Night Watch can seal
the gates with ice and stone if they
need to or during times when they're not
using that particular gate or if they're
under attack
the Nights Watch built 19 castles and
they've never actually man doll them at
the same time I think 17 is the most
that they've ever had people and all
together over the last 300 years as the
manpower of the watch has dropped most
of these castles have been abandoned
right now they only use three of them
and sometimes they just sends forces to
different abandoned castles for periods
of time the ones that they use are
Castle black which is the largest
maintained castle that's loaded located
at the end of the Kings Road and held by
nearly 600 brothers they also have
people at the shadow tower which is the
westernmost end and maybe like 200
people might be there and then we have
eastwatch-by-the-sea the port of the
Nights Watch with the smallest garrison
located at the eastern end at the wall
the Nights Watch
cuts down trees that are close to the
wall so they leave like a half mile
buffer zone over time you know they have
crept back closer to the abandoned
castles because they don't have the
manpower to go out and keep that part
clear it's a lot easier to protect the
wall than it is to attack it so that
means a small group can hold off a much
larger force defenders are generally
beyond the range of bows or catapults
and in turn rely on archery catapult and
dropped objects to shower down pain on
anyone who tries to approach to attack
there are only two choices a head-on
attack it you know of the gates which is
pretty difficult or sending a party over
the wall to attack the gate from behind
we've seen this idea in action when John
was pretending to defect he went over
the wall with a team of wildlings but
then came to Castle black to warn them
of the impending attack the wall was
built to defend the realms of the first
men the men of the Nights Watch have
reportedly defended the wall against
others and other monsters for 8,000
years since the end of the long night
according to legend the wall was built
by Brandon the Builder with the
assistance of the children of the forest
and giant and is protected with ancient
spells and sorcery also according to
legend the wall is vulnerable to the
Horn of
notice that the two most important
things we think we know about the wall
come from legend bran the Builder is who
we think of as the walls creator but
think about how long a thousand years
actually is the Great Pyramid in Egypt
was built around 4,500 years ago so
8,000 years is a crazy long amount of
time the idea about the children's
involvement and the Horn of Joramun is
also noted as according to legend and
the facts that spells are woven into it
is attributed to myth this doesn't mean
those things aren't true but it does
indicate that the story may have changed
depending on who passed the story along
part of the language here would be due
to the maesters who liked to paint a
picture where magic doesn't exist we
know this is false because we've seen
clear-cut examples of magic which by the
way appear to be increasing at this
point in history so here's the thing
there was a long night where winter
lasted a generation as far as we can
tell the story is told throughout the
world and even though the details are
different it's a strong indication that
something like that happened Westerosi
legend says that when this was going on
the others or the White Walkers advanced
south to wreak havoc on mankind the
show's version of the story tells us
that the children created the White
Walkers as a weapons weapon against men
who would they were losing war with I'm
not at the opinion that this will be
different in the books because it pretty
much makes sense like most things how we
get to birth to the reveal and what we
learn about their intentions will be
more complicated but overall this is
probably something george RR martin told
D&D once things got out of control with
the white walkers and everything seemed
lost the last hero is said to have
sought out the children for help from
there the Nights Watch was formed and
the combined forces were able to win
what's known as the Battle of the dawn
the others apparently retreated to the
land of always winner and in the end no
one knows the fate of the last hero of
course as our story is concerned we are
more familiar with the Zora high which
is a strikingly similar story from the
east and there are many others such as
the Lion of night from even further east
from these stories prophecies have been
born where there will be another long
night that could once again bring about
the end of men prophecy aside the one
thing that we know came out of this
period of time is the wall a giant
barrier meant to protect the First Men
and all the other men who came after
them from the
White Walkers and their armies of the
dead an engineering feat that makes it
one of the wonders of this world and one
that has been a constant in an
ever-changing round the Nights Watch has
continually manned the wall as a neutral
force for eight millennia
during which time there hasn't been much
white Walker activity in fact the only
other event that involved the wall and
the others was the corruption of the
thirteenth Lord Commander which is a
whole other story and remember that Jon
Snow was the 990 eighth Lord Commander
so that was a long time ago leading up
to the events of the song and Ice and
Fire series the black brothers are
mostly concerned with keeping watling's
out so much so that even when people
hear of the encounter with the white
walkers in the big like the very
beginning of the series they don't think
that much of it that is where we are now
our story began with signs that the
White Walkers were moving south over
time the wildlings realized they had to
do something which led to their
migration this brought them into
conflict with the Nights Watch who were
blocking their way south with said wall
jon was the only one who could wrap his
head around the idea that leaving them
on the other side was a recipe for
making lots of whites and this has
helped along since he was at hardhome
and when it happens in the show as we
know the crows who had been fighting the
free folk for generations couldn't get
onboard with John's plan and chose
mutiny over working together now we have
the end of the show coming up and it
seems like there's just no way the wall
isn't gonna come down before the story
is complete I'm in the camp that thinks
Sam has the Horn of winter in old town
so not sure if that will play a role or
not I could do a video about the Horn if
you want but the show seems to be
pointing us in the direction of bran
playing a role in it coming down since
the night kings mark broke the magic
that was keeping the White Walkers out
of the cave and since benjin mentioned
that he couldn't pass the wall while at
the same time sending Brandon there many
fans think that the mark will have the
same effect if bran passes through the
wall there's so many other things to
think about I should probably just end
the video here let's look at what the
wall means and what it might mean if it
comes down until now with only one
exception that happened thousands of
years ago the walls existence has
deterred the others from moving south of
course it's complicated but we know that
there were hard and long winters over
this time so on some level it seems like
they chose to stay away there
a pact which was broken or they may be
reacting to some other change like the
rise of magic that we see going on the
truth is we don't know all the details
because things like these get lost over
time back in 2000 when asked about the
construction of the wall george RR
martin said this the interviewer said
would you mind giving a brief
description on how the wall was
constructed Martin said much of these
details are lost in the mists of time
and legend no one can even say for
certain if Brandon the Builder ever
lived he is as a remote from the time of
the novels as Noah and Gilgamesh are
from our own time but one thing I will
say for what it's worth more than ice
went into raising the wall remember
these are fantasy novel this brings us
full circle with Hadrian's Wall nowadays
people send their prisoners to the wall
to get rid of them brothers of the Night
Watch spend most of their time freezing
to defend this huge structure from small
bands of wildling Raiders that's not to
say that there weren't some important
events that have gone down at the wall
but for the amount of time it's been
there things have been pretty quiet
couple that with the idea that so much
time has passed that people who aren't
from the north and art they're just
barely aware of the significance that
the wall once held so let me know what
you guys think and let me know in the
comments if there are any other videos
about the wall you want to see was bran
the Builder a real person and did he
build the wall with the help of the
children and giants like the legend says
was there a pact involved or do you
think the others just took off and
haven't been back yet if there was a
pact how did it get broken is the birth
of Danny's dragons and other magical
occurrences related to White Walkers
coming south and is the wall definitely
without a doubt coming down and if so
how you have to admit building a giant
ice wall to keep ice creatures who are
really good at working with ice out is a
little bit hard to figure don't forget
that I've got a giveaway going on and
all you have to do is be a subscriber
and leave a comment when I hit 18,000
subscribers I will pick one comment and
send that subscriber a copy of a night
of the Seven Kingdoms so please like the
video if you liked it and subscribe for
your chance to win thanks for watching I
will talk to you soon